Republican legislators are offering to
let North Carolinians choose where to
send their kids to school
I'm declaring this state of emergency
because you need to know what's
happening if you care about public
schools in North Carolina
it's time to take immediate action and
tell them to stop the damage that will
set back our schools for a generation
here's what's happening in the next few
weeks
their private school voucher scheme will
pour your tax money into private schools
I'm so scared right now you shut
up oh no here's what's going to happen
in the next few weeks their scheme is
going to let you send your kid to good
schools instead of the bad schools that
you're currently forced to send your
kids to the horror
though that state of emergency
declaration seems a little bit odd since
nearly 70 7-0 percent of North
Carolinians support school choice